i came here from the u.s and i don't
have any place to live
i don't know what we're gonna do i'm
nervous about the baby
i'm here alone my mom left i'm the one
who's stressed out not you
ariella hits a breaking point with
binium
after sacrificing so much she's starting
to feel like
it's just not worth it the only reason
i'm having a baby here is for you
if we're not getting along then why am i
gonna stay here like i have a few weeks
left i can travel
you know like so i still i can leave now
but it's not that simple binium's past
has just as much of a hold on ariella as
it does on him
i don't want to lose my family again the
pressure is
real hey 90 day fans fam it's melissa
this week's episode of the other way was
the mid-season finale
cheer but don't worry i'm going to
update you
on where every couple stands
including the interesting news about how
summit's parents found out he was dating
ginny jenny and my wife they were
talking to each other
they were spending very good times with
each other
it's juicy i'm also going to give you a
rundown of what we can expect when the
other way returns october 11th
there are people who genuinely hate him
now and
they might decide to kill him
intense right before we get into that
let's start off with ariela and binium
who went apartment honey
during this episode and came across an
apartment
that ariela loves but benium
he can't afford oh my god we have hot
water
okay i like it i like
it uh how much is it a month
it's forty five thousand a month forty
five thousand
is the wi-fi connection strong of course
yeah
i like it i think it's much better than
everything else we've seen so far it's a
lot bigger
i mean you know you know that like has
really expensive like
so in us dollars the apartment's about
1400 a month but binham revealed that
with his four jobs he won't even make
half of that
he still has his eyes set on his
cousin's two-bedroom apartment
that's under construction but ariella
she's not having that my cousin's
apartment
still is cheap 6 000. no we can't
it takes time things takes time no it's
not
i will show you for one week i'll finish
oh you knew i was coming
you could have had everything fixed in
the apartment ready already if it was
about money you could have asked me for
the money
so it's your fault yeah i'm so busy for
practice and i tell you
oh but i thought it only took one week
you could have taken one week off
practice because it's only one week to
fix everything very
true well at this point ariella has
pretty much lost her patience and mr
binyam
he's getting sniffy if you like his
other [ __ ]
what i like i can't live in a place that
has no bathroom and no kitchen
why can't listen to me shut up
if you agree we can fix it for one week
everything whatever you want
i know what i want it doesn't work like
that are you construction
no but i'm logical
just one week are you patient for one
week no
no no i'm not staying here i told you
that
oh my god we just have to wait and see
if ariela is going to stay in ethiopia
for the long run but based off of the
teaser
she has some really difficult and
terrifying experiences in store
we are going to deliver vicente section
we will not wait
so when would i have to have the wave
today
what relax
if you don't baptize the baby goes to
hell
you're gonna let your sisters talk to me
like this you act like
these aches now i swear that's really
what's wrong with you it's my baby i
don't have anyone here i can talk to
it just makes me want to go home
well summit is someone who can
definitely relate to ariella
he is familiar with risking it all for
love
here's how he and jenny ended up on the
mid-season finale
i'm meeting my parents with the hopes of
my parents will accept
jenny in my relationship
jenny has tourists with us so we have to
leave the country in every six months
we want to get married before harvesa
expire
to let her stay here in india
and they're not ready to accept any i
just want to
make sure that they're not gonna mess
with my marriage
while summit's parents were preparing
for him to come to the house
they dished out some very and i mean
very enlightening news apparently
they had a friendship with jenny they
had a friendship with jenny
before they found out she was secretly
dating their son it was 2 30 13
when she came
she told us that she's his she's a
indian
facebook friend and she want to visit
india
she want to live with us
i saw him that he was talking to her
a lot in the night time he was sleeping
and he was with jenny
i'll be honest the way they're painting
this story
makes it sound pretty disturbing
summit's dad said when he realized they
were more than just
friends he was shocked mainly because of
jenny's age
relationship
this drama between summit and his
parents makes
even more sense now they feel as if
they were bamboozled by jenny
i want him happy but not with a
lady more than double of his eyes
it was my dream to play with my
grandchildren
yes my ass are dreams i have to
make them understand me and jenny love
each other it's a true love
and that's what more important in the
society of things
[Music]
when the other way returns we'll be able
to see exactly how their talk went
for now we did get a tease of his
conversation with jenny
afterwards well i'm not asking you to
give up on your phone not gonna give up
even if you ask so are you sure that i'm
who you want to be with
all right moving on to brittany and
gazan
during this episode britney received
urgent news
that her divorce hearing is scheduled in
chicago in three days
so she immediately booked a flight back
to the states
but of course she didn't tell you zion
all
the details when you want to drop it
why do i want to travel yeah well i want
to go back to
you know chicago because i have some
stuff to do there and you know my sister
is having her baby
remember yeah so
i'm not completely lying to yazan i'm
just not telling him the full truth
of why i'm going to chicago yazan had
suspicions
that something was up he was pretty
upset when brittany left
you don't think i'm gonna come back huh
no just i wanna be sure
i love you honey i love you
[Music]
know
[Music]
well when britney returns to jordan she
is going to face some
unimaginable circumstances
based off of the trailer i'm getting the
gist that
yazan's life is in danger i must be
careful
it's jealous how is it dangerous
there are people who genuinely hate him
now and
they might decide to kill him
that's terrifying well in south korea
jihoon is feeling the sense that he has
his life
back devin's mom returned to the states
and he feels like
he can breathe again but he has to keep
in mind that
it's game time he has to step up for his
family
that includes making sure he's staying
faithful to devin
which she'll question him about when the
show returns
have you ever cheated on me i just
wonder if there's
more going on that i don't know
well kenneth and armando ended things
off by
saying goodbye to kenneth's girls who
were visiting and preparing for the
moment
they've been nervous about all season
their trip to go visit
armando's parents
i'm worried about my dad i just feel
like he's trying to avoid us
last but not least tim and melisa
just might need to call it quits during
the episode
tim revealed to me lisa that he kept his
job in the states for backup
which pissed her off because she was
unaware of that
but she also revealed that she's keeping
a big secret from him
and based off of the teaser for the rest
of the season
these two might be reaching a point of
no return
i would like to know if you've been
having sex with somebody what for for my
own
sanity i don't think i need to tell you
all right 90 day fans fam the other way
might be taking a break but make sure
you stick with et
to stay updated on all the latest news
from the 90 day universe
i'll see you next time